>> Laura: CNN RANG IN THE NEW
YEAR WITH SOMETHING RARELY IF
EVER SEEN ON NATIONAL NEWS.
A REPORTER HOLDING A JOINT AND
LITHE A BONG.
-- LIGHTING A BONG.
THE NETWORK COVERAGE INCLUDED
LIVE SHOTS FROM RANDI KAYE IN
DENVER WHO REMINDED VIEWERS IT'S
LEGAL IN COLORADO.
GAS MASK WITH ME SO I WOULD NOT
GET THE CONTACT HIGH.
LOOK AT WHAT IS ON THE OTHER END
OF THE GAS MASK.
YES, A BONG.
OKAY.
NOW WHAT?
YOU WILL CELEBRATE NEW YEAR'S
EARLY.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS WHAT A GAS
MASK IS USED FOR.
WOW.
>> RANDY!
>> THIS IS FOR ANDY.
THIS IS FOR YOU.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> [LAUGHING]
>> ON CNN!
>> Laura: WHAT A TOTAL DOPE.
A DOPE SMOKING DOPE.
A MOTHER OF A GIRL AFFECTED BY
MARIJUANA CALLED CNN'S COVERAGE
A FREE INFO-MERCIAL FOR THAT
GROUP.
I WAS ON THE DANCE FLOOR DANCING
THE NIGHT AWAY WITH FRIEND AND
TELEVISION.
BUT, YOU AS A MOTHER WHO LOST A
CHILD TO SOMEONE IMPAIRED WHILE
TAKING MEDICAL MARIJUANA, I
>> IT WAS VERY OUTRAGEOUS TO SEE
WHAT I WOULD CALL THE
>> Laura: THEY ARE SAYING, IT'S
FUN AND GAMES.
CORRINE, IT'S LEGAL IN COLORADO
AND NOW LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY DID A BIG RIBBON CUTTING
CEREMONIES AND LOVELY MOMENTS
MY DAUGHTER JENNIFER HAD JUST
GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE.
SHE WAS 22-YEAR-OLD ON THE VERGE
OF A WONDERFUL CAREER.
SHE WANTED TO FIGHT DRUGS.
SHE BEGAN HER FIRST JOB.
NOT IN HER FIELD OF STUDY, BUT
SHE WAS CALLED INTO WORK AS A
DISTRICT MANAGER INTO ONE OF THE
STORES WHEN AN ALRM OFF.
AS WE WENT IN, SHE WAS T-BONED
ROAD THROUGH SHRUBBERY AND THE
DOORS OF A BUILDING AND THE
BUILDING ON COLLAPSED ON TOP OF
HER CAR.
MY DAUGHTER LOST HER LIFE THAT
NIGHT.
THE MAN THAT DID THIS WAS
UNINJURED, BUT HE WAS HIGH ON
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
HE WAS GIVEN A VERY LIGHT
SENTENCE OF JUST 2 YEARS IN
JAIL.
ONLY SPENT 17 MONTHS THERE.
NOW HE IS OUT AND OFF PAROLE.
>> Laura: IT'S INFURIATING.
ALL WE HEAR ABOUT IS HOW
MARIJUANA IS THE ONLY THING YOU
CAN TAKE TO EASE PAIN.
ANYONE CRITICIZING IT IS
HEARTLESS.
"NEWSWEEK" ATTACKED ME, I WEAR
THAT AS A BADGE OF HONOR, FOR
HAVING A SIMILAR REACTION TO THE
CNN COVERAGE AS YOU
I TWEETED OUT WE WILL SEE HOW
THIS WORKS OUT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
MORE POT HEADS AND INCREASE IN
PSYCHOSIS AND MORE IMPAIRED
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PEA
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PIE
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PIECE
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PIECE S
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PIECE SAY
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PIECE SAYIN
"NEWSWEEK" RAN A PIECE SAYING
OH, I AM SCARED.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO TO YOU IF
SEEING THIS LEGALIZATION
MOVEMENT GROW NATIONWIDE.
HOW TO GET INVOLVED GIVEN YOUR
OWN LOSS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO IS 12
YEARS OLD.
WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY ELSE DYING
ON THE ROAD.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO CONTACT
OUR SENATORS AND GOVERNORS AND
STATE OFFICIALS AND TELL THEM
THAT WE NEED MORE EDUCATION IN
THIS AREA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE FILLED WITH
MISNOMMERS PUT OUT BY THE
MEDICAL -- THE MARIJUANA
INDUSTRY.
IN THE '70s.
THIS IS A VERY POWERFUL DRUG.
IT CAUSES PSYCHOSIS AND MANY
OTHER THINGS IN PEOPLE THAT
SMOKE IT.
THE MORE WE LEGALIZE IT, THE
MORE YOUNGER PEOPLE ARE TRYING
IT AT EARLIER AND EARLIER AGES.
>> Laura: EVIDENCE IS BUILDING
AND GROWING.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE THE
COURAGE TO COME ON TONIGHT.
EVEN THOUGH EVEN HATEFUL THINGS